we're using the meijer tebow reunion as
the springboard for today's draft
reunions in the nfl we would like to see
trivia question for both of us chris i
don't know the answer and i have a
feeling i may not know it i don't ever
read it yeah there have been five
players to play in the nfl not play for
at least eight straight seasons then
play in the nfl again
can you name
one of them
this has to be something that happened
like
like during the war like byron wizard
white or something like that i i i i
mean alden smith did that go that long
no no right no um
i know hold on don't give us answers yet
i mean i the the first thing when i
think of longs about i think of dick
vermeel but of course he's not a player
i i really have a hard time he was not a
player thank you but i'm just saying
like what who who are we missing there's
one pretty recent
matt
fairly
man i can't think of everybody and you
know and this is one of those where this
is one of those where it's so obvious
that you you just
you feel like you you you freak out like
i can't i can't process it i should know
this i should know this i should know
that i'm i'm just the answer doesn't pop
through no and i'm trying matt
our crazy you know producers telling me
i worked with the guy before
and he says both of us have
what what is he talking about he's out
of the nfl for at least eight straight
seasons i'm gonna be really embarrassed
out of the nfl there have been five
years of play at play in the nfl not
play for at least straight season eights
and then play eight straight seasons and
play in the nfl again i i don't get it i
give up i i i who is it who is it tell
us somebody
uncle
who is pop too can we get the names oh
doug flutie wendy damn it how did i
forget that
but you know what i didn't realize it
was that long eight straight seasons wow
doug flutie
david diaz and fonte
tony adams
ross nagle and frank tiger walt well who
can forget
frank tiger walton i i was i i was
thinking of
i was thinking of frank lyon walton
wasn't thinking of frank tiger walton uh
doug that's a tricky question though
because he still played that was a tough
it's not like he he he stepped away from
football together okay
tom brady tim tebow slight difference
could have gone to the cfl and he chose
not to all right uh you can take the
first pick since we were both all right
thanks um okay uh you know what i want
to see bill belichick go back to the
giants that's what i want to see if you
want me ask me one reunion that's the
number one thing on my list i would love
that of course the giants are my
favorite team i'm a huge fan of bill
belichick and of course the boston new
york rivalry rivalry is very real so i
would have always liked to have seen
that you know there was always those
rumblings remember like back four or
five years ago where
there was like rumblings that maybe
belichick was thinking about the giants
and things like that i don't know how
real they were but i would have loved to
have seen it
gary myers was pushing that a few years
ago the the year after the jimmy
garoppolo trade and the report came out
there was disrespect and seth wickersham
had all that more recently wickersham
suggested that it was the giants and a
couple of other teams that belichick was
talking to but
belichick was always under contract with
the patriots that was never going to
happen it was never going anywhere and
it was explained to me at the time very
simply it's going to take him five years
to get any other team to where he has
the patriots right and he doesn't want
to waste five years
spinning his wheels trying to get
another team to the point where the
patriots currently are so he's just not
leaving he's just he's not okay um
well i look i go belichick and tom brady
just i mean if i want if i want a true
reunion if i want to have a couple of
personalities get together again
mend their fences i say that uh bill
belichick and tom brady end up together
again on the giants
on the giants okay yes
let's do the job yes
the the team the team that has been the
thorn in tom brady's side the team that
took away his undefeated season for
which he supposedly would give up two
super bowl rings if he could have that
perfect season and something else he
said on the draft-a-thon a couple of
weeks ago yes belichick and brady on the
giants all right you're up all right um
oh i got some good ones here i'm really
not sure
you know listen for theatrics and
everything like it the way it ended
i would love to see
antonio brown back with the steelers and
mike tomlin and big ben i mean come on
you know that crew up there all those
personalities you know just to see how
they would react with that how that
would actually end up working out and
everything like that i mean from that
standpoint that that's can't miss tv
with that crew up there and i would be
interested to see if big ben and ab
could strike up the the same chemistry
they had and how that would go and if it
would get smoothed over and everything
like that so that's one that that was
the first one that popped in my brain
honestly when i when i heard about this
draft
you know it's amazing how how quickly
you forget the things you did last week
but as we were getting ready to
interview juju smith schuster last
monday there was some sort of technical
thing as we were getting it all threaded
and i i made an antonio brown crack and
and i don't think either he didn't hear
it or it didn't conveniently ignored it
[Laughter]
um all right uh how about mike mccarthy
and aaron
rodgers mike mccarthy he hates everybody
so who cares fans won't go better the
devil you know than the devil you don't
know at some point mccarthy and rogers
who wouldn't that be great not that it's
going to be with the cowboys but
maybe maybe what happens is
rogers ends up with the 49ers mccarthy
gets fired by the cowboys and he gets
hired to be the offensive coordinator in
san francisco the same job he had when
the 49ers passed on aaron rodgers in
2005. boom that would be yeah that would
be amazing shanahan coaching them
mccarthy the oc and rogers the
quarterback i'd like that that'd be uh
that would be awesome to see certainly i
didn't think about that one either i'm
mad i actually didn't think about that
that was a very good one by you i got a
few good ones here i don't care if you
steal him at the end i mean i do think
about i'd like to see marcus peters with
the rams again and him and jaylen ramsey
on the same team obj to the giants
the raiders to oakland right but here's
one and i cheated a little pete dim a
little lighter light of lightest gave me
this one all right i'm gonna i'm not
gonna lie here
the oilers uniforms i'd like to see them
reunite with houston so they could wear
them as throwbacks right i mean the
tennessee titans have they're holding
them hostage because i believe they
still own the rights to those unis and
everything about it but come on that's
part of houston they don't drill for oil
in tennessee let the texans have it back
so they can wear it for a throwback
every now and then they probably do
drill for oil at tennessee they do
um
that that is a you you know i like it
when you say i've got a lot of good ones
you rattle off three or four that aren't
very and i take the worst one one that's
your hammer is one that you didn't even
come up with
uh i'll go i'll go uh man look at that
oh what's up
is this earl gonna run over the guy here
isaiah robertson watch out watch out
isaiah it's oh my god gosh oh there it
was
jersey too i wonder where the remnants
of that jersey are today where is the
remnants of that guy's chest
i was thinking the other day yeah um we
were talking about the rams the first
football helmet i ever had was this
cheap little blue helmet from sears with
horns that didn't completely finish so
it wasn't a copyright infringement
that thing's in a landfill somewhere i
mean it doesn't degrade like where is
that thing now i don't ever think about
that i know stuff end up how did where
did it you're right it'd be like one of
the great sports relics of all time i
mean that would be one that people would
bid big money for
all right i got one more pick to make
but we got to take a break so i have
extra time to think about it so it can
be better than chris's more pft live
right after this
all right i got one more pick for our
draft of the reunions we'd like to see
this one goes way back this one goes way
way back this one goes back
27 years
come on jerry jones come on jimmy
johnson
together again bring him back how about
them cowboys i haven't won a super bowl
since jimmy was there
come on men fences
break bread
sing kumbaya
and uh hey we've already fired mike
mccarthy so the cowboys need a coach
bring back jimmy johnson i i like
first off is he in the ring of honor yet
have they officially haven't even done
that yet right i don't think they've
done no i mean that's amazing
that just shows you how bitter it is
there but i know that was
hey man that was must watch tv the
cowboys with jimmy johnson and jerry
jones is amazing
five seasons together yep they won two
super bowls they put together a team
that won another one after johnson was
gone i mean come on people life's too
short i mean seriously just the general
observation anyone out there find a way
to get along with people they did great
things together how could that have
happened chris i don't know i really
don't
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports